Let me ask you a question. Which
religion glorifies Jesus apart from
Islam? Islam is the only religion that
glorifies Jesus, believes in Jesus,
believes in his miracles, believes he's
the Messiah, honors his mother, believes
he's going to come back. No other
religion, look, Jews, do you know what
Jews believe about Jesus? They believe
he's is in hellfire and burning in his
own feces. Do you know what they say
about Mary? They say she's an adulterer.
[Music]
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran, gives you reminders. Download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your makyama that you read it.
wherever you was. But are you Christian?
Uh, yeah, trying to be. Oh, that's good,
sister. Um, we, do you know, we Muslims,
we believe in Jesus, obviously. You
know, he was a prophet. Yes, we believe
he's a prophet and we believe in his
mother, Mary. We believe she was a
righteous woman and she gave birth to
Jesus. So, we believe in Mary, uh, the
mother of Jesus. We believe in his
miraculous birth, but we don't believe
him to be God. We believe he never
claimed to be divine. And we believe he
was a prophet sent by God. And, uh, we
believe the final message is the Quran.
So you have the Old Testament, the New
Testament, and we believe this is the
final testament. Yeah. If you have any
questions. Yeah. And who do you believe
God is? So we believe God is the
ultimate power. He's not a man or a
woman. He doesn't have a father or a
mother. There is nothing like him. He
has no beginning. He has no end. He is
the sustainer. He provides for
everybody. He looks after Jesus said
that he son of God. So son of God is
mentioned in the Bible for many people.
For Jeremiah, for Adam. So son of God
means someone righteous. So sons of God
ask you a question. Yes sister. So what
do you think of Muhammad? So we believe
prophet Muhammad is the successor. So in
the Bible Jesus said I have many things
to say unto you but you cannot bear them
now. For he when the spirit of truth
shall come. He shall guide you onto all
truth. He shall not speak of himself as
he hears he shall speak and he shall
glorify me. So now who is that? He the
only thing that puts me off is Muhammad
got married when she was 14. No, no, no.
You're talking about Aisha. So the thing
is the thing is this sister, we say we
have today's time and we have 1400 years
ago. Yeah. The prophet Muhammad was a
different time. No, it was like for
example, you're you're Irish. How old
would you guys get married roughly?
About 16. 16. But your mom when did your
mom get married? 16. And her mother? 16.
Usually from my time married at 18, but
she was 16. Good. Okay. Usually like
even my grand great great parents yeah
they're married at 12 13 14 what we're
saying is this sister we can't judge
someone based on our present time
because you know what even you married
at 16 some people will find that odd
yeah and also come from it because in
the Bible it speaks about how if someone
was married and the brother passed away
there was not somebody else yes it was a
very likely exactly so those times were
a very different time so what we say is
the prophet Muhammad peace upon his
marriage to Aisha. It's we he waited for
her to become an adult. Now you can't
look at kids still like how was your
son? Three. He's 3 years old. Yeah.
Okay. So kids at the age around 9 10 11
were going to war. So they were
providing they were working for their
family. So we look at kids today. Forget
kids. You get grown men playing
PlayStation. So the times are different
times sister. So it's based on that. And
even Joseph he married Mary at the age
of 12. He was 19. Jesus coming back. He
says that. So we we believe as Muslims
Jesus will come back. So Jesus is the
Messiah. He's going to kill the
Antichrist. He will come back. But he
will come back to tell the Christians.
He never said to them that I am God or
worship me. Yeah. But he said I am I am
and he also said everyone said to
yourself he come Jesus when he come to
the earth he come humble. He didn't say
I'm the son of the living God and I and
everyone should worship me. He came
humble. He done everything that he was
meant to do. basically like yes he he
wasn't any way better than anybody else.
Yes, of course. But he came if you look
at the Bible in the entire Bible. Look,
I've got a Bible here. In the entire
Bible, sister, he did not once mention
ever mentioned to be God in the entire
Bible. This Bible is humongous. Yeah.
There is the verses where Jesus clearly
glorifies the father. What does Jesus
say in John? Say I am the beginning and
the end. No, he doesn't. He does not.
That's no. No, he doesn't.
is someone else associates it to him.
Yeah. Yeah. But but you know if we go by
that way you know Melkisedc Yeah.
Mechisedc he has no mother has got no
beginning no end of days. No father no
mother. Jesus. Yeah. Cuz Jesus said what
if Jesus said if I have him if I take
him without dying what is it to do with
you? No, but but you say when you say
the alpha and
omega has said something which is more
than the alpha and omega. He said no
beginning of days, no end of days, no
mother, no father, no genealogies. Jesus
peace be upon him has got two
genealologies in there. Luke and
Matthew. Yeah. So, so, so the so the
thing is one minute. So, the thing is
Jesus if he speaks when he sees it, he
says, "I am going to my father and your
father." To my God and your God. Can God
have a God? No. Good. So why is Jesus do
you not believe in the father, son, the
holy spirit? No, no, no. Because not me.
The Bible doesn't believe that. Jesus
glorifies the father. Every time
somebody came to him and said, "Good
master, what must I do to get eternal
life?" He says, "Why do you call me
good? There is only one good and that's
God alone." In the book of Acts 2:22, it
says, "Jesus of Nazareth, a man chosen
by God." That means Jesus is not God.
Chosen by God with wonders, miracles,
and signs which God did by him. So it's
very clear. So do you believe that Mary
was Virgin Mary? She's a righteous
woman. And do you believe that uh
basically Jesus the holy God's holy uh
spirit descended upon her? Yes. Yes.
Yes. Yes. So we believe the Holy Spirit
is not God. But the Holy Spirit
descended on Mary about the birth she's
going to have miraculously which is
Jesus. But we don't believe him to be
God. Jesus never claimed to be God. In
just one thing John 17:3 Jesus says so
they may know you have eternal life. The
one true God and Jesus whom you sent. is
clearly saying there is one true God and
Jesus whom you sent.
So what about the the father, son, and
the holy spirit? She's asking me
questions. Yeah, don't blame me. The
father, son, and the holy spirit. The
father, the son, and the holy spirit.
They they came later. They was made
later. There was never the father, the
son, and the holy spirit. Jesus always
worshiped God alone. In the mountain of
Gethsemane, he fell on his face and
prayed. Pray to who? If he's God, who is
he praying to? So what? And and can God
die? Do you believe God's going to die?
No. So Jesus died in Jesus was living
flesh. He was the son of God. Put on the
No, but you believe he's the son of God.
Christians, if you say I believe him to
be the son of God and not God, they'll
say you can't be a Christian. You're
more close to Islam. Different ways.
Listen. No, they say there's different
Muslims. True. But all these different
Muslims, my husband there, he's best
friends. Every one of his mates are all
Muslims. Yes. But you know the
difference. They all have different
perspectives. They say the same thing.
They don't believe Jesus is a fraud.
True. But they all have different
perspectives. Let me tell you the
difference. What's your name, sister?
Een. Eileen. Alen. My name's Ali. Sister
Eileen. Listen. In Islam, all the
denominations that differ with each
other, they all agree on one thing.
Allah is the one true God. The prophet
Muhammad is the final prophet. Jesus is
a prophet and the Quran is the final
prophet uh message. None of us say, "Was
Muhammad the son of God? Was he a part
of God?" Even though we have our
differences, we believe in the main
thing. I don't really know. I have not.
But what's Muhammad's story about?
Okay, we believe he's prophesized that
he's going to come. So Jesus said,
remember he talked about the successor.
Jesus says, "I've got many things to say
unto you, but you cannot bear them now.
For when he, the spirit of truth shall
come, he shall guide you onto truth and
he shall glorify me." Let me ask you a
question. Which religion glorifies Jesus
apart from Islam? Islam is the only
religion that glorifies Jesus, believes
in Jesus, believes in his miracles,
believes he's the Messiah, honors his
mother, believes he's going to come
back. No other religion. Look, Jews, do
you know what Jews believe about Jesus?
They believe his is is in hellfire and
burning in his own feces. Do you know
what they say about Mary? They say she's
an adulterer.
So, we Muslims, we glorify Jesus.
I personally I don't know. To watch the
full discussion, guys, just click the
link here or in the description box.
Inshallah, this will take you to my new
DA channel, Ali Dawa Raw, where from now
on all my da discussions will be aired.
Go now and subscribe now and enjoy this
video. Inshallah on that channel.
Asalamaikum. We better get to